in this world there are good guys
and there are bad guys
and i will not be bullied into submission
You're reading the mans part
oh god
Would you like to start over
yes i would
i will not be bullied into submission
sorry to interrupt your wife is on line 2
Im interested in real parts
Got 83 dollars in my bank account and I don't know if I can pay
my gas bill. Ruth, there's an audition
They're looking for unconventional women,
whatever that means. Hello ladies,
I'm Sam Sylvia and this is GLOW. Sorry,
what's GLOW? Gorgeous Ladies of Wrestling.
Are you hiring actors to play wrestlers,
or are we the wrestlers? Yes.
Christ, fucking actresses. Okay, I want you
to meet the star of GLOW, Debby Egan
Are you insane? Why is she here? She's the Alpha you're the Omega. Submit. She might kill you.
This is the Backson Howard our producer
This is my first Hollywood party.
There are drugs in the fucking robot. Thank you.
Wrestling is about type: you're a sexy party girl, you're an arrow
You mean Stereotype. Yes, bingo exactly! You're a big black girl.
The fuck you say?
Lady wrestling, I get it.
Women can do anything men do blah blah blah
How'd that look? I got chills.
Yeah you would.
We're empowered, we're the heroes. want the show to happen this is the
only place ticket to you what I want to
do people respect me here we got to
shoot this thing like five weeks this
could either feel dinky or it can feel
epic so let's give them one but yet
storytelling storytelling this is about
justice this is about holding on to
what's ours
gorgeous lady
you